e aí a gente o canal do bom vocês aqui
está bem como está muito bom saltar
melhor porque tem uma galera que estava
com minha tudo engano meu juízo
o ifaz um filho chato isso ao vivo chato
eu não sei não quero isso vou precisar
aqui no google agora ale como adiantou o
comandante
é bom voltar a esse carro aqui é
possível chapa equipe que tem que
evocará acaba mesmo é bom né deixar o
chato não como a charlie charlie que
desonerar lixar a bem a brincadeira do
chá anunciar a brincadeira de invocar um
gente que brincadeira é essa nova moda
do momento é fazer a brincadeira do
charlie charlie é o que você pega um
papel coloca duas canetas uma reta e eu
tô lá fazendo mais assim você escreve
não e sim de um lado e sim e não de
outro você perguntas como charlie que é
o do satanás e ele responde pra você sim
ou não brincadeira de invocar os atlétas
bairro a juventude eu vou ligar pra
polícia ou é da polícia as crianças de
hoje passaram do limite passar do limite
eu lembro que o meu tempo as brincadeira
era escolhas conde era pega pega o
diabetes não repetir o esconde-esconde
pega pega agora evitar o diabo tem muito
de repetir que o charlie charlie quando
surgiu o tempo dos das calça colorida
que a galera falava-se em caraguá irmão
hoje é o tempo das calças coloridas será
que um dia da bunda vai virar moda
também e hoje eu cheguei pra vocês com
muito medo no coração porque se hoje a
moda invocar o satanás com certeza a
próxima da bunda tão certeiro como é que
há gente que as crianças de hoje que se
faz com as crianças de hoje foi meu
filho tudo bem tudo bem mas você estava
brincando hoje eu estava brincando hoje
cima onde é que você estava brincando
brincando de bocha é normal você brincar
é povo um pega pega
era uma salada mista evocando um satanás
normal é as crianças de hoje são assim
vai dormir nessa pai bem sua mãe boa
noite meu filho que deus abençoe vá
dormir tá tudo bem mamãe você conversar
um pouco com o capiroto já dou muita
gente o méxico essas coisas nossas
coisas gente nem fica invocado chaiwan
advocacia estou charlie brown ninguém
volta melhor que bono vox a chave do
menino que vai pra caramba que charlie
brown e charlie brown você está aí ele
chega desse vôo que leva fred que o
jesus maria josé e vai levar a lugar
nenhum e agora só quem é que não gosta
dessa brincadeira o bicho papão o
lobisomem o velho do saco todo mundo
fica chateado com isso porque a gente
não tem mais medo deles ainda só tem
medo do charleroi um dia desde que fui
fazer essa brincadeira do charlie
charlie loura do banheiro e saiu disse
beleza né
tinha medo de richa e fim e outra pessoa
que deve estar muito chateado com essa
modinha é o próprio charlie o que aqui
no brasil meus amigos meus amados amados
irmãos e vou falar igual igual pacto
para espantá lo se tiver que o charme
vai embora porque aqui no brasil eu amo
a coisa quando ela vira ufa quando ela
fez para não tem quem aguente o coitado
desse charro não deve parar de trabalhar
agora nenhuma achar você tá aí corre pra
mudar me para mexer a canetinha passa o
dia todo em fazer isso dá york chega em
casa o bichinho vai deitar verdes que
fosse a cara não aguento mais vou
descansar aqui outra pessoa lá no
maranhão chave você tá aí ele sai
correndo uma porque ninguém paga em
manaus aconteceu a parada o menino foram
brincar com esse negócio aí o charlie em
vez de brincar brigou foi com o corpo
dela entrou foi bem esse rumo na minha
no chão mas parei para se bem que está
até uma ideia para a gente é que a gente
pode fazer a gente pode apresentar chapa
ou inimigo nossa a não gosto de você seu
inimigo não gosto de você você é um
idiota tinha não gosta de você seu lixo
merda - o inscrito eu sou seu inimigo é
que se faz se falam cara você não chega
aqui eu tenho um jogo bem massa pra te
apresentar aqui jovem foi massa joga e
puxa o jogo charlie brown é o jogo chave
pra você não falo pra
fala só o chato a gente o conselho que
dá pra você não me acho que essas coisas
não faz um jogo a jesus jesus se está na
minha vida
jesus jesus me ajuda a passar no enem é
muito melhor é que mexer melhor decolar
de baixo mas não está atrasado eu tô
aqui em araguaína foi um show ontem para
você fazer o que cê é araguaína hoje já
que ele avisando logo a galera de cuiabá
galera de cuiabá mato grosso dia 13 eu
tô chegando aí dia 13 no holiday em às 7
horas em show aí tá informação a
descrição do vídeo galera de são paulo
são paulo capital dia 18 de julho eu vou
estar aí a wii onde é que é como é que
eu faço pra comprar o ingresso no teatro
elis regina no anhembi você comprou
ingresso ingressorapido.com.br e também
na descrição desse vídeo é de picos no
piauí meu piauí no piauí dia 6 agora
próximo final de semana vou estar aí tá
no pico com esse evento o picoense
eventos do bairro e poeiras como
congresso como não sei que como é que eu
faço pra está tudo aqui na descrição do
vídeo tá e se você tiver gostar desse
vídeo que você faz é que gostei que no
youtube está no facebook clique em
curtir no facebook marca os seus amigos
no facebook assistir esse vídeo parar
com essa brincadeira não vai à frente e
escreve o canal nunca perder os vídeos e
nós falamos de serrano este negócio
chávez reúne está a ser só uma diversão
da galera ó charles xavier você tá aí